hello I'm alone Rebecca
institute at carnegie mellon now the
department that I'm part of is robotics
which is a whole lot of Technology work
but I run something called the create
lab which stands for Community robotics
education and technology empowerment and
that's a little unusual because what we
are all about is empowering people with
technology to change their own world and
in fact this project charge car is a
very important empowerment project so I
have to start by telling you how i got
empowered about electric cars and how
that's led to where we are now so these
are the two cars that I have built in my
life or driven in my life i should say
the car on the left is the stanford sun
surfer that i was involved in building
and racing across the country and the
car on the right is a toyota rav4 EV
that I still drive daily and this thing
was sold to me in the year 2000 and it
has continued to work without ever going
in for service anywhere so that's 12
years of perfect running and the only
thing I've done has changed its tires
there's two important lessons I learned
about electric cars about the ability
that they have to engender community
engagement just with these two cars with
the one on the left I understood and
appreciated how elegantly simple
electric cars can be because they have
so few moving parts less than one
one-hundredth as many moving parts as a
gasoline engine car well the one on the
Rights taught me how engaged and excited
the community at large is about the idea
of electric car transportation I drive
this car every day and all manner of
parts of Pittsburgh where we do outreach
program from the create lab everybody
knocks on the window and asks questions
and wonders how many miles does it go
can I get one please what kind of
batteries does it have questions like
these and so in fact what we determined
with this car which again is elegantly
simple it doesn't break down at all and
works in the winter works in the summer
no problem is that the range it has
which is 120 miles and the way that we
get to interact with people on the road
leaves them desperate for access to
possibilities access to possibilities
that don't require gasoline that don't
require constant service and maintenance
that don't have the kind of street noise
that we that leads to loud streets and
crowded streets and polluted streets on
our cities on our city's neighborhoods
so that's where this project began and
now the beauty of having a robotics lab
is that you can have your students hack
commercial vehicles so in fact we hacked
that electric car got into its computer
system and started to note what kind of
measurements of power there are going in
and out from the batteries to the motors
and back and that was interesting
because we weren't expecting something
that has so much noise up and down as
you can see there's a whole lot of
discharge events below the flat horizon
line and is a great deal of charging
events for instance when you're stopping
at a red light or a going down a hill
that's all the peaks that are going up
above the horizon what was interesting
about that is the idea that an electric
cars battery is doing something that
batteries aren't really designed for
very much which is its massively
switching rapidly between charging and
discharging all the time as you drive it
around the city as you slow down in
front of somebody speed up again stop at
a red light speed up at a green light
you're constantly in the world of
switching the direction of current
transfer on the battery on it when we
measure that and start to do some
statistics we saw some really
fascinating things for instance even
though my entire commute ends up using
net five kilowatt hours of power to get
to CMU from my home in squirrel hill in
fact twenty-seven percent of the time
I'm charging the battery rather than
discharging it which is really
interesting it's a recyclable
rechargeable battery but the battery's
life ends up depending a great deal on a
total amount of work it's done in this
lifetime and that depends on how much
it's charged and discharged so it's
interesting about this number is it
leads us to think about hypothesizing
ways to use batteries and electric cards
more intelligently using control and
optimization from computer science so
that you don't end up wasting time
charging it but instead find other ways
to store the energy and return it to the
car without having to use up your
battery life now the charge card project
came out of this realization that in
fact computer science and computational
thinking has a role in how we build the
car of the future so we work on all
areas of model design how do we create
electric car models control how we
actively manage the energy and electric
car everywhere from designing and
controlling the thermodynamics of the
battery how we cool and heat it to
predicting how the human drives
and using our predictions of what's
about to happen next to properly control
the batteries inputs and outputs and we
even have at the very bottom community
engagement the idea of learning how to
talk to local communities and have them
envision together with us engineers how
the car of the future can be part of
their network now one interesting
engagement angle is to give people a GPS
unit and teach them how to use it to
record their commute so we created a way
for people to take any GPS record their
commute and then upload it to a website
we created called charge car and this is
active and you can go there now what's
exciting about that and by the way more
than 100,000 miles worth of people have
noticed this website and used it is that
when you upload your data to charge car
it immediately computes for you if you
were in an electric car how big were
your battery would have had to be for
your commute and how much work with that
battery have done and how much gasoline
money would you have saved if you had
had an electric car on your commute so
this website allows you to immediately
visualize yourself with an electric car
on your commute so we take data that
matters to you and allow you in a more
intimate way to imagine your future with
a different kind of the energy vehicle
some of the interesting things that
we've noticed for instance this is a
plot showing the total amount of energy
required for various commutes of all
these hundred thousand miles that have
been uploaded to our website but you'll
notice that whole lot of the miles more
than fifty percent of all the commutes
in our database need one and a half
kilowatt hours of battery power total
that's less than two 12-volt batteries
so when we talk about
hundred-thousand-dollar cars or sixty
thousand dollar cars that have 30 or 60
kilowatt hours of power like a Tesla
Model S that's well and good and that's
a fantastic machine but if you think
about what people actually need people
for whom the price of gas actually
matters because there are low-income or
middle income folks for them a car with
the equivalent of two lead acid
batteries of energy would get them to
work it'll be simpler to operate and far
cheaper in terms of cost of maintenance
over the long run and that to us is very
exciting now where do we take this where
we take this skews me for that is we
take it towards the idea
of taking a car like a Honda Civic and
coming up with a way to convert a used
car into an electric car and so where I
leave you with is the creation of our
electric garage a facility where we
actually trained mechanics to take
gasoline cars and take all the gasoline
elements out of the car just like this
and turn them into an electric car put
an electric motor keep even the clutch
plate so that the car's manual
transmission still works and end up with
a car that's a completely electric
charge car this car goes more than 45
miles and can be done as a conversion by
an independent auto auto technician in
an independent garage in about two and a
half days now that's exciting because
we're recycling and community engagement
point of view you're creating local
labor and local local local jobs with
local mechanics you're using local
materials which is a used car rather
than spending all the carbon fruit and
baking a new car and you're creating
something that as a niche product may be
able to fulfill certain people's needs
as a comedic vehicle so we've created
electric garage right here at Carnegie
Mellon University across the street on
off of Forbes Avenue and that electric
garage houses events where we have
people like Jay apt come and give
speeches about the electric industry we
have events where for instance West
Virginia Wheeling Jesuit University will
come and show off their electric
vehicles including their formula racers
and we screen movies there in the
evening for instance we showed who
killed the electric car and a number of
other movies like gas lands right there
inviting the community of Pittsburgh to
come and enjoy talking about cars about
transportation ecologies and about how
computational thinking in computer
science can lead to a type of car that
could truly solve real problems here on
earth with that I end but i want to show
you both our corporate collaborators
such as Bosh which is funding a great
deal of our work on optimization
bombardier which funded our work into
electric people movers Intel Corporation
which has given us computer systems that
are in every one of the electric
conversions we do and zipcar which helps
our ecology by hosting to zip cars at
the electric garage so now any person
driving electric car can park the
electric car at the electric garage
charge it with our eighth generation to
charges that we have set up there thanks
to ethan corporation they can take the
bus from there or they can jump in a zip
car and
go off from there so now we've created a
center a nerve center in Pittsburgh for
not just electric cars but for
intelligent alternatives in
transportation finally the highest
Foundation has funded us to actually do
the community engagement that allows us
to communicate with the public and
expose them to the idea of this kind of
research gone to the real world thank
you